when you are lending to a business you
you know that you're taking a risk it's
a loan it's not a donation but we are
with you 50% 50% meaning that if there
will be a default and I want to say we
have hundreds of businesses that already
received loans and there aren't any
defaults yet yes it's young yes we have
to have patience we're only running for
the past um year and a half um but there
aren't any defaults yet but we do have
these funds to know that if there will
be a default we'll be there together
with our impact lenders and putting in
50% of that default for them to receive
at least 50% of what they put
[Music]
in N or welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here with me
how are you fine thank you thank you for
inviting me um I think I'm okay okay
with everything under the circumstances
I'm doing okay yes and the the answer we
all uh we're all accustomed to give and
here over these last few months
unfortunately and but today we're we're
here to talk about something really
exciting a problems place that you're
you're passionate about and is sparkel
the organization that you are the CEO of
looking at peer-to-peer looking at the
at the intersection of peer-to-peer
Israel and you know there's a lot of
different moving pieces that are that
that I'm really excited about all of
them separately but you're combining
them into one uh one organization and
One Vision so I'm looking forward to
hearing a little bit more about that but
also your own journey and and then that
of spark I as an organization beyond the
problems space so again AMA thank you
thank you for being here and uh before
we even get started about anything tell
me a little bit about yourself you
know who are you and then what do you
really care
about so I think the most appropriate
thing to say these days I'm a mother of
four and I have two my two eldest sons
are in Gaza for the past almost three
months
so I have um I would say sleepless
nights I think that's what the most is
how I can characterize how I am I'm very
very very proud of them um but as a
mother I'm also worried um but I try to
keep myself very very busy and luckily I
have an amazing amazing um position job
none of them I call that I I feel like
I'm a candy store because everything I
do is really what I love doing
um so I can just dive into it um most of
the day besides the fact that I also
have two daughters that b and a husband
and um and friends and I volunteer and I
sit on boards but at the end of the day
I think that at this time
um everything that's happening in this
country and around around the world with
the Jewish people that's something that
is constantly on my mind I carry this
with me all the time I go every um
Saturday evening to to uh Tel Aviv to be
with the families of the hostages I just
feel they need our support as much as we
can and um I even want to mention that
person that started spark that put all
together the technology for spark is
John paulen that his son hirsh and
Rachel's son hir is a hostage
for7 days already in Gaza and I just
want to send here um our prayers for all
the hostages to come home really quickly
and safely and especially especially to
Don and Rachel that Hersh will come home
to them you know hopefully um you know
this is going to air just a a couple
weeks I'm uh deeply uh optimistic and
hopeful that that by then and he he's
already back and oh I pray so hard yes
so tell me a little bit about
you know what what the what this whole
world is that that spark L is involved
in you know how do you how do you define
it you know how did you even get to
it so there are a few problems that we
are sitting out to try to help in this
world I would start by saying that one
of the issues that we're dealing with
with is fair credit for very small
businesses in Israel small businesses um
are comprised about
97% of the businesses in Israel it's not
that difference around the world because
small businesses at the end of the base
economy of of a country um but when you
look at the credit that they receive at
Banks we're talking about 16% only the
what we are doing at spark is even the
16% is also reduced by because we are
helping small businesses that are
riskier that the banks are not um
willing to help they can be um
businesses of of marginalized
communities they can be businesses from
the periphery they can be social
businesses and these businesses many
times are overlooked by the bank or
traditional banking I would say and we
are here to see how we can help them how
we can help these businesses be be um
Thrive how can we help them at the end
of the day bring food to the table
because at the end a business a small
business is a family is a community and
we understand that the having small
businesses Thrive is a goal that is
super important for the economy of
Israel we'll get to the war in a second
but this started way before the war it's
not something that we decided to happen
since the war that's one one of the
problems that we're we we're trying to
um to help out here at spark the second
problem is Jewish engagement we see
anti-Semitism Rising we see the fact
that younger Generations are less um
connected to to Israel we see that there
are many many miden I would say in this
connection as well and what we're doing
at spark is the peer-to-peer lending
that you mentioned is all about Jewish
engagement all about engaging Next
Generation to Israel to help them
understand that there's a new way of
philanthropy it doesn't have to be the
traditional philanthropy it doesn't have
to be just to donate large sums we're
looking at impact lending which is
something new that we're trying to into
the field and saying you can be an
investor but it's not that you're going
to get any um um interest on your
investment so it's all about social
impact lending so does it does it make
sense to say that the impact lending is
is the solution to the problem that
you've that you've attributed that said
you know we have these this line of
businesses they operate under certain
conditions under certain geographies in
certain problem spaces there are reasons
why the traditional Mech the traditional
banking mechanisms perhaps don't are not
relevant for them and and I'd love to
hear even just a little bit about you
know what are these main criteria and I
have some intuition about that but I'm
curious to hear what what you've what
you've understood and that the way to e
to solve that is through the more social
social side and peer-to-peer lending is
that the right framing of it it is I
think there there can be different
solutions but at the end of the day
because there these businesses are risky
and because and since we need you all
need them um the solution of peer to
peer lending is definitely an optional
solution there could also be investment
there could be many other things but at
the end of the day they don't exist and
um we've learned from Kea Kea was the a
model that started in the US 17 years
ago all about um impact lending and Kaa
is a platform that has been running for
17 years helping out small businesses
and private people in developing
countries doing very much like what
we're doing which just doing it all
interest free um
and since Kaa does not operate in Israel
since Israel is not a developing country
um then we the whole idea was how do we
create a model that is relevant to
Israel and can be keom for Israel and we
call it sparkel but it all also takes
into consideration not only impact
lending it takes into consideration how
do we create a stronger engagement for
Next Generation to Israel and to
Israelis specifically because when we'll
go into a little bit about what spark is
you can at the end the point is to help
out a specific person that you want to
invest in that impact lending so you're
helping out Sarah you're helping out
Jamal you're helping out Natasha you're
helping out these specific people when
you go on the platform you can decide
who you want to help and how much you
want to help them and and and that's how
you decide who you want to lend to and
you'll receive your money back so that's
a new kind a new model that we're
bringing into the market I would say but
all all all doing good no one's ging any
interest no one's taking any Commission
of these loans everything is going one
to the other
100% um and it's just we are a mediator
of connecting the ones that need and the
ones that are wants to help and we're we
are creating a Marketplace just to bring
them to to the same place in order to
help each other phenomenal and the I
think the you know a main question that
stems from this and and by the way this
is all you know really really amazing I
mean this is just uh you know truly
doing good and then allowing people to
support people um and and not just
donate or contrib and it's not a
donation it's it's a lending so there is
so you're but but you're doing it in a
highly personalized way through choosing
the things that you you deeply care
about um I'm I'm curious about the con
the context of drisking obviously every
lend is not is not risk-free and I'm I'm
curious how you've experienced this Con
this concept of risk in the social
lending environment that I think you
know transcends beyond the the Israeli
nature here and you know how what what
is the play that risk has in your in
your ecosystem in your model so um
that's an excellent question I should
say at this point that we are an
organization we're a nonprofit
organization that are we have I we spark
has two owners one is the Jewish agency
and I will give here credit to amila
that is the CEO am the CEO of the Jewish
agency sparkel is her idea initiated in
her mind seven eight years ago and is
now coming to life and her um owner is
the Ogen group Ogen has been a social
bank they are um the Israel free loan
Association for the past 30 years they
have 30 years of experience in
underwriting so we are all Outsourcing
of all the underwriting we're doing to
the businesses is done within oin so the
expertise is there and we're learning
more and more with the unique businesses
that we're bringing to the table I will
say that um yes of course there are
risks taken here
I will also say that we approve only 40%
of the loan of the requests that come
through because we check to see a few
things one are they able to give back
the loan if they're not able to give
that back the loan and we are um a sort
of bank at the end of the day we have a
license from the Israel Market Authority
um so if someone will not get back their
loan this is not a social um Venture
that we're trying to help because at the
end of the day they need to give back a
loan and we don't want to bring them
down even more um um not being able to
take other loans from other places so
one we check if they have ability to
bring give back pay back their loan we
also check to see that the purpose that
they're asking for the loan also makes
sense what they they need it the amounts
to be sure that they're going to good
use and they're not asking just for
money to replace money that they are
getting interest from that's not the
point of the loans we want the
businesses to grow with is with these
loans we want the businesses to expand
and not for them just to change loans
with other loans since this one is
interest free and the third I also want
to say we are helping um businesses with
a sort of philanthropic money so we want
to be sure that these businesses cannot
receive these loans from other places
that they if they can receive a loan
with interest since they're strong
enough or if they have money sitting in
the bank and they don't want to use it
just and they want threee M loans they
are also not relevant to be spark uh
businesses that will receive loans from
us so the underwriting goes it's a very
very thorough process um that we check
all the background needed we have all
the information that they they need to
apply with all their Bank information so
we go through it very very um seriously
um and I also want to say that we're ra
we we have raised already um five
million shekel I'll TR translate that in
a second to dollars but um for five five
yeah there these are risk mitigation
cushions meaning that good at the end of
the day when you are lending to a
business you you know that you're taking
a risk it's a loan it's not a donation
but we are with you 50% 50% meaning that
if there will be a default and I want to
say we have hundreds of businesses that
already received loans and there aren't
any defaults yet yes it's young yes we
have to have patience we're only running
for the past um year and a half um but
there aren't any defaults yet but we do
have these funds to know that if there
will be a default we'll be there
together with our impact lenders and
putting in 50% of that default for them
to receive at least 50% of what they put
in um and and that's the mechanism that
we're building and because again this is
a new social startup this is what it is
uh we'll learn as we move forward and I
know and and all the time updates and
understand really the needs and what's
happening um I think it's important also
to say that when someone lends to a
business they receive monthly payments
business has up to 60 months to PR pay
their
loan um and when you once you lend to a
business let's say you lend to a
business
$60 um you decide you want to help umia
she has a she's a has a barber shop and
she um um n she's a um a new imigrant
from and she's amazing um and you want
to lend $60 to help her with her WR you
will receive back a dollar every month
out over the 60 months that she bring
she justy pay back her loan okay with
the money that accumulates in your
account and and you can then either Rend
that amount as you're going to another
business so the first initial dollars
can go a long way to another business
and they come back into another business
or you can decide to withdraw that
amount because it was a loan and it
wasn't a donation so we what we are
purposly doing and planning on doing
even more is telling you okay you helped
imig we have a new immigrant the
platform do you want to help her as well
do you want to transfer the funds that
you already received in order to help
another business and really see how we
can shift the first lending um the first
I would say act of giving but we call it
lending um and to see how we can just
mobilize more and more that's amazing
that's very very cool H I'll show
briefly because it's
a do it com I had a an idea that I was
uh thinking for quite some time back in
the University there were some students
that couldn't uh that couldn't afford
bicycles um they were on scholarship
they couldn't afford bicycles to go to
class one of them was one of the most
brilliant computer scientists and
Engineers that I that I saw and I he
would come late to class every single
day and I got so upset and I said why
you know why are you coming late you're
you're one of the best you came all the
way to Stanford you know why are you
late and he said that he doesn't have
money for a bike and it's a large campus
I was thinking how is that possible that
some people with extraordinary potential
IAL don't have the capacity because he
doesn't have the right social credits he
doesn't have the right credit score and
ability to get a loan right from the
bank and um and what we what we actually
ended up doing was was providing him was
getting a group of us together friends
providing him um the the the money to
buy a bike and some other things now
instead of expecting to get it back what
we did was we agreed that when he goes
out and he'll he already had offers from
some amazing companies to work for he'll
use he'll once he makes a a certain
amount of money a year he'll need to
find two students who can't afford bikes
and he'll have to do and he'll need to
duplicate the agreement and we said you
know maybe in 20 years we'll have a tree
here
[Music]